Can't believe Ciri did this.
She killed our brothers in our home.
That thing ain't Ciri.
Get anyone who's left.
Grab all the elixir you can find.
We don't know what she can do.
You don't want to escape.
I want Ciri back.
The monster mash is
an epic battle between basilisks,
Voleth Ciri,
and everyone at Kaer Morhen.
Yennefer told me to…
Shit.
It is the finale of the season.
It's the big bash
through which we can tell
the final strands of this story.
Yeah.
Release her…
and you can have me.
That is enticing.
All he really wants is to protect Ciri.
And that is his one goal.
The very person
that he's trying to protect
is actually the monster
who is trying
to kill him and all of his brothers.
The monster mash
is basically me beating up
all the guys,
which was so much fun.
Ciri!
Geralt has to battle it out
with his daughter.
No.
It was a lot of fun.
I felt very powerful.
It is basically
an all-hands-on-deck battle,
and it's pretty epic.
The other monsters
that we reveal there
are basilisks.
What the fuck
kind of basilisks are those?
I'll tell you after I kill 'em!
I don't see how things
could get any wronger!
Jaskier spends most of his time
under a table,
as is right and proper.
I got to do a small fight with Henry.
I love all the stunt stuff.
We had a lot of fun.
It was one of the few times
in shooting the show
where we all kind of felt like family,
so it was… Yeah, it was fun.
I loved it.